hey what's up everybody this is pat
flynn from smart passive income calm and
smart passive income podcast I wanted to
create this video for Tim and for all of
you out there we're going to be starting
your podcast very soon specifically to
teach you how to record and edit using
GarageBand now if you aren't going to be
using GarageBand because maybe you're a
PC user or you might prefer something
else like audacity or adobe audition
that's okay
most of those pieces of software all
work the same way and this video will
still be extremely helpful for you
because I'm going to show you how to be
incredibly efficient when piecing your
show together because hopefully you'll
just be doing more than one episode now
before we get started I got some
housekeeping things to take care of
that's going to make your life so much
easier down the road so let's dive right
into my computer and I'll show you
what's going on all right so here you're
on the whiteboard which is where I'll do
I'll be doing some instruction here for
you let me just say what's up to all
Tim's family what's up toons fans
uh now when creating the episode there
are some people out there who have the
ability to complete an entire show in
one full session meaning their intro and
outro music and even their interviewer
sort of recorded live and all pieced
together in one moment and by the end of
that their episode is ready to ship I am
NOT one of those people and most of you
probably aren't either and I found it
very convenient to think of a podcast
episode sort of like a like a movie
that's made up of different parts that
when put together just create sort of a
seamless show and that's how I want you
to think about it so I'm going to talk
about the different kinds of files or
the different pieces of your show parts
of your show that you can potentially
have all recorded separately and pieced
together so the first thing you want to
think about having is something like a
pre-roll and a pre-roll is a unique
identifier for each particular episode
so for example might sound like hey
what's up this is Pat Flynn and welcome
to episode 108 of the smart passive
income podcast and that is very useful
for people because a if they've listened
to that episode before they probably
know you know it's good to have order to
all of your episodes but secondly you
know it gives good identifiers for
people if they want to share it or
reference it later
now that is typically followed by the
intro music which is always good to have
not everybody has intro music but that's
okay you could choose and that's a
really bad note but you could choose to
have music if you'd like that's up to
you and the music is typically followed
by your intro you're sort of what you
know again a unique sort of introduction
or welcoming for each particularly
episode after the music and this is
actually really important because this
this within typically the first minute
will be the deciding factor whether
people stick around or not and in that
intro you want to give all the juicy
sort of teasers that you can to make
sure people continue to listen on
because if you don't give them something
to look forward to they're just gonna
they're just going to leave now if you
do have interviews this is typically
where you'd put the interviews and five
then you might do sort of a unique post
role you know something to end the show
typically you want to put a call to
action in there as well and then six I
didn't give myself enough room the outro
music and now each of these different
things can be different files that you
could sort of plop together in a
timeline let me show you how to do that
in the next segment but before we do
that I want to talk about some specific
types of files that you should have
handy so that when you do open garage
band or whatever editor you use it'll
just make it incredibly easy for you to
find them alright so right now you're
looking at a sample podcast folder and I
think it goes without saying that you
should obviously have your own dedicated
folder for your particular show but the
way you organize those folders within
that podcast folder is really important
so let me go over how I organize the
folders and this is again for maximum
efficiency and organization so first you
can see here obviously a folder for all
the episodes so every time you create a
new net a new episode they get saved in
there there's one for all of the
graphics that you have from your cover
art to you know anything that anything
promotional for your podcast as well
that goes in there you also want to have
a folder for all of your recorded
interviews so whatever recording
software you use plop them in there and
then also I like to have a folder for
screenshots because you're going to want
to take record of you know the high
rankings you get in iTunes and elsewhere
now let's look at these master files
really quick this is what's going to
save your life having master files
incredibly and easily accessible for you
each time you create a new episode so
you can see here I have three master
audio files here which will be easy to
drag and drop into your timeline so I
can I have one for your intro you can
have one for your outro as well and then
if you have any audio transitions in
between different segments of your show
you can have them in there as well and
to keep it easy I just have them with
little dash and
and all caps so that they're easy to
find the - just puts them at the top
when they're put in alphabetical order
now you'll also see a master episode
template here this is my GarageBand
master episode template and this is
important because it's a file that you
create that you'll open up each time you
record a new episode that will already
be set up with all the proper track
names and settings for your show this
way you don't have to start from scratch
with each new episode and mess with the
settings each time so let's get into
GarageBand right now and I'll show you
how to set up your master template and
then after that I'll go over a sample
episode with you so you can see just how
easy it is to piece your entire show
together okay so as soon as you open
GarageBand you're going to be asked to
create a new project now this is the OS
Mavericks version there's going to be
new versions in the future and you might
be using an older version of GarageBand
either way you're going to be creating
your master template file the same exact
way so open up an empty project and hit
choose and then you'll be asked sort of
what you're going to do with your
particular file now again remember
GarageBand was made for musicians so
there's a lot of instrumental things
going on here we don't need that you
just want to record using a microphone
and just make sure the input is on input
one typically unless you're doing
something different it's going to be on
input one if you're using the line-in on
your iMac or your MacBook Pro so I'm
just going to hit create to start our
master template file now here's the
interface that you're going to be
familiar with down the road I'm not
going to go over every single bit and
piece of it but I'm going to give you
some specific things to do right and
immediately after you start this file
again this is to make it podcast
friendly because typically musicians are
using this software so the very first
thing you want to do is turn off the
metronome and that can be found here on
the right hand side it looks like Cal
Bell you know we need more cowbell but
not when you're recording a podcast
episode what this is is it keeps time
for those musicians that are out there
using this software but we don't need
that so we're going to turn that off
we're going to also turn off this count
in which is sort of a pre sort of four
counts before you start recording we
don't need that the last thing you want
to do is also change the sort of LED
area here from beats to time so you want
to show the
because you want to know sort of how
long you're recording and sort of what
time you're at in different parts of the
show we don't need to know what bar or
measure we're in so those are the first
two things if you're not using this
version you can look around in the
settings to change again turn off the
metronome turn off the count in and
change from beats to show time so those
small little setting changes actually
are really helpful for you so you could
actually save this master template file
right now if you'd like however there's
a few more things we're going to do with
the tracks to make our life easier
so that we'll know when we drop in our
audio files exactly what's going on so
let's organize our tracks here you'll
see one track here called audio one
we're going to add more tracks specify
them for different parts of our show
which will make it easy to drag and drop
them in later so let's do that right now
so we're actually going to rename audio
one to our pre-roll so if you just
double click this you can change the
name so we'll make that pre-roll and
then we're going to add a new one by
clicking this plus button and we're just
going to make it the same sort of
microphone line input audio file and
then I'm going to rename that one to be
intro music and I'll just fast-forward
through all this so that you'll see them
all when they're done all right so here
we are with our tracks already laid out
and I'm going to go down the list for
you really quick but before that I want
to reiterate why this is important to
organize your file this way it's
important because you know for one it
just makes it easy to organize and to
know where things go when you're
dragging other files into the into its
place here but it's also important
because in the future if you ever wanted
to change anything out it would be
incredibly easy for you or if you go tim
ferriss style a VA to come in and do it
for you for example if you wanted to
change the intro music or you've changed
it later and you want it to make it
cohesive from episode one you can come
into your older episodes and just
interchange the music here or maybe
you're adding or taking out or changing
advertiser's down the road if you had a
track for advertisers you could do that
now again these lists of tracks here
this list here it's just a
recommendation you can add your own
tracks if you have other things you
could subtract tracks it's up to you now
let me go down the list really quick you
have your pre-roll your intro music your
introduction and you'll see two
do different interview tracks the
purpose of that is one track for your
voice and one track for the person
you're interviewing the reason you want
to separate those tracks and I'll show
you how to do that in a second but the
reason you want to have them separated
here is because sometimes the people you
interview they don't have the best audio
quality or their levels might be too
high or too low
you can adjust them here to match yours
so that it's just a seamless sort of
audio experience going through your show
then you also have your post role and
your outro music as well another thing
you could do to make your life easier is
if you know that your intro music is
going to be the same in every single
episode that you have you might as well
include it in your master template file
to drag and drop any audio file into
your timeline in any track here I'm
going to show you how to do that right
now so open up your find your find an
audio file doesn't have to be an mp3 it
could be like a wave or an A iff you can
drag it and drop it right into that
particular track so this is the intro
song so I'm gonna put it into this track
here and you know for your template file
I wouldn't worry about where it is
because you can move it around later if
you'd like but I'm just going to have it
there and you know I'll play it for you
just really quick so you can hear it
welcome to the smart passive income
podcast and that's it so you can see it
going across this timeline it's made up
of different waveforms and you can even
move and shift this into different
tracks if you'd like it's really easy
and intuitive but for now I've done all
I can to prepare my master template file
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to click file and save as and I'm
going to name this the - master episode
template so it'll always be at the top
and hit save and congratulations you
have your master template file the file
that you're going to open every time you
record a new episode the most important
thing to remember is when you open this
file to save as the new episode that
you're recording or else you're going to
forget and you're going to overwrite
your master template so that's it now
let's reopen this file and do just that
and then record our first session
together actually really quick let's fix
just a couple more things let's
highlight the pre-roll let's move back
to 0 and we could turn off the library
by clicking off this button here to give
us more room and then let's save it
again that way when we reopen it it'll
look just like this
okay so when you reopen GarageBand
you'll see the same screen as before you
can actually go to your recent files and
open the file from there or you can just
go to your Finder window and open it
here as well alright and here we are
back at the timeline now what's the
first thing we do when we open this
template file we save as for this
particular episode so I'm going to go
into the episodes folder and create a
folder that is named 0 0 1 since this is
episode 1 it's good to have a specific
folder for each episode as well in case
you wanted to record different versions
or you wanted archived versions or
whatever other things to go along with
the episode it's just nice and clean and
then I'm going to name this zero zero
one dot band band is just the garage
band a file extension and here we go now
we're all ready to record our pre-roll
so what I'm going to do that for you
right now this intro song is here
already which is good but I'm going to
move it out of the way because we don't
need it now you could also mute it if
you'd like by clicking this mute button
underneath which I turn to blue and I'm
just going to make sure the pre-roll
track is highlighted and then when I
press this red button it's going to
record and then I'll whatever I say will
be recorded into the episode so here we
go hey everybody what's up this is pat
flynn and welcome to episode one of the
sample tim ferriss podcast there we go
we're done now let's listen to it hey
everybody what's up this is pat flynn
and welcome to episode one of the sample
tim ferriss podcast now did you notice
that click sound for my mouse at the end
we obviously don't want that in there so
I'm going to move the sort of timeline
cursor here a little before the end and
you'll sort of see where you're speaking
based on where these waveforms are and
I'm going to hit command T that splits
that track at that point in time and
you'll see it's highlighted and I can
just hit delete and it goes away so now
let's listen to it again hey everybody
what's up this is Pat Flynn and welcome
to episode one of the sample Tim Ferriss
podcast boom all good to go
now let's unmute the master intro and
I'm going to scoot it over back here
again you'll be able to see where
everything lines up again remember that
graph I made sort of pretending it's
sort of like a movie well this is
all the magic happens so now I'm just
going to test it a little bit you can
just click around and see how it sounds
and again I can make it you know I can
shift it around if it doesn't sound good
but let's play it
various podcast welcome to the smart
sounds good now if I want to get a
bigger overview of what the show looks
like as far as a timeline I can use the
horizontal zoom here sort of zoom out
just to get more of an idea of what room
I have and of course it only goes up to
a minute now because we haven't recorded
anything else but I'm going to do more
right now and you'll see it just go up
over time but next I'm going to record
the introduction now making sure the
introduction track is highlighted I'm
going to record and you'll hear the
episodes intro before I record that's
there to help me again I don't want to
mute that because I want to know exactly
when it's time to come in so again I'll
do a very short truncated intro for you
because this is just a tutorial but here
just check it out I'm gonna hit record
right now and what's up everybody Pat
Flynn here thank you for coming on to
today's episode I appreciate you guys
blah blah blah
today's episode so and so forth don't
miss it and at the end make sure to
catch this this and that boom here we go
here's the interview with Tim Ferriss
and stopped it and there we go so let's
hear how all that sounds together hey
everybody what's up this is Pat Flynn
and welcome to Episode one of the sample
Tim Ferriss podcast welcome to the smart
passive income podcast where it's all
about working hard now so you can sit
back and reap the benefits later and now
your host who cannot wait for football
season to start again Pat Flynn what's
up everybody Pat Flynn here thank you
for coming on to today's episode I
appreciate you guys blah blah blah
today's episode so and so forth
don't miss it and at the end make sure
to catch this this and that boom here we
go here's the interview with Tim Ferriss
and we're done now I'm going to zoom in
here a little bit so I could see the end
and just so I can make sure to get rid
of any clicks that might be there so
again come
and t delete and again that's kind of
how the show is put together now let me
give you some tips as far as the
interview is concerned I'll drop the
interview track I did an interview with
Tim Ferriss a while back and I'll just
sort of put that in here I'll add the
post roll and outro music and then we'll
be done and then I'll show you some
tricks for exporting and making sure
everything is leveled off as well but
let me go into the interview folder
really quick just to give you some tips
as far as the interviews that you're
capturing if you're using call recorder
for skype this is a tool by ECAM you'll
see that the episodes that you record
are the interviews that you recorder
actually movie files and the reason it's
a movie file is because you know you
could record a movie you know the the
what's on the screen if you're actually
seeing video but since it's audio it's a
movie file but it's just audio and you
could actually change this to an mp3
directly from the tools that ECAM and
call recorder provides you right here in
your finder by right-clicking and go to
open with now you could just convert
this directly to an mp3 it turns it into
an mp3 file and then you could drop it
in a timeline in one track but I like to
split movie tracks there's split size
the conversation or split movie track I
just found that split movie tracks is
just better as far as the vert is the
quality that comes out so I'm just going
to click split movie tracks and it'll
take a little bit of time but you'll see
in just a moment that you'll see track 1
and track to show up okay now one of
these tracks is actually my voice and
the other track is Tim's voice now here
I'm going to do the same thing except
turn it into an mp3 so now I'm turning
each side into its own mp3 which I'll
then drag and drop into the timeline so
I'm going to open with convert to mp3
the latest version this is track 1 takes
a little bit of time but you know I'll
fast forward for the purposes of this
tutorial
all right and so now we have the Tim
Ferriss interview track one in Tim
Ferriss interview track two and I'm just
going to shrink this down so I could
show you how to drag and drop them in
here and so we have track one where to
go track one I'm just going to drag it
right here and it takes a while to
convert especially because these
interviews sometimes go for several
minutes but just be patient now I'm
going to do track two I'm going to make
sure the beginning is at the same point
in time as the other one because again
you want the conversation to be very
natural I mean if it's off a little bit
somebody is going to answer before
somebody else finishes a question it's
going to be weird it's happened before
it's okay you can always move these
things around if you don't get it right
now just let me zoom in just to make
sure yep they're at the same time and
now I'm going to play the beginning of
this however note that typically when I
start recording these interviews and
this might be the case for you I'm not
recording at the very moment we actually
start the part that we want in the
podcast and just might be small talk but
I'm not going to play the whole thing
for you I'm just gonna play the
beginning so let's see what it sounds
like right I'm all yours
here we go three two one what's up
everybody I'm so happy to welcome back
mr. Tim Ferriss the smart passive income
podcast what's up Tim how are you I'm
great
I'm enjoying Hawaiian weather in San
Francisco while it lasts alright and
that's it now I'm just going to cut this
short so I'm going to highlight both of
these click command T just to delete all
that because I want the tutorial to be
very short for you obviously
but that's track 1 in track 2 and as I
play these I could notice the different
levels here you'll notice that as I was
speaking you've probably seen this
already or have noticed it because it's
the only thing moving on the screen but
these levels sort of go up as the voice
becomes louder and if they are in the
red like for a very long time that's
going to mean that the people listening
it's going to crackle in their earphones
or on their computer you don't want that
to happen the if the audio is in the
yellow or maybe just a tad bit at the
bottom part of the red that's good and
you want both tracks to be there luckily
Tim was on some good equipment which
he's told you in this particular
a tutorial for the podcast as well so
there's no worries there but like I said
before sometimes people aren't on good
equipment or their levels come out
different but I'm going to show you a
little trick even if you can't you know
mess with the levels enough where it
sounds good there's a tool out there you
can use to make the levels of everything
in your episode all the same and I'll
show you how to do that in just a sec
but let me just finish up here
with the post roll and then I'll drab
dropping the out outro music
and then we'll export so I'm going to
highlight post roll and I'm going to
just come back a little bit so I can
prepare myself Francisco while it lasts
alright I hope you enjoyed that
interview with Tim Ferriss you can find
him at all the places you all know where
to find him and you could find me at all
the places you all know where to find me
thanks melting in the next episode that
was a terrible outro obviously you want
to call to action you know subscribe to
my email list download my ebook here
that sort of thing but again just for
this tutorial and then the last thing
I'm going to do is plop in the outro
music so let's get the outro music here
as well and again I can move it around
and I'm not even going to play it for
you but you kind of get the idea so let
me kind of zoom out here so you'll see
exactly how this episode is laid out
pre-roll the intro music the
introduction the interview on two
different tracks the post roll that I
just recorded and then the outro music
and there you go so that's the episode
so now what you want to do is click
Share and export song to disk and this
is where you'll get a few different
options I like to name this the same
exact as it was before zero zero one and
I wanted to do it as an mp3 just comes
out a lot better as far as file size
because the end you're gonna be doing a
lot of these but you know you know let's
look at these qualities really quick you
know medium or high is okay I mean
typically if you're doing music highest
quality is what you want but you know
you have some music in your show
typically so I mean I usually do it at
high quality and click export and it's
not going to take much time because this
is a short episode and boom we're done
so we'll see the file here let me go
into episodes and then episode 1 you'll
see the mp3 file and you know if I
wanted to I
play this and we could hear what it
sounds like hey everybody what's up this
is Pat Flynn and welcome to episode 1 of
the sample Tim Ferriss podcast welcome
to the smart passive income podcast
where it's all about and I'm not gonna
play the whole thing for you but that's
that's the idea now the last thing I
want to give you is a tip for level
leveling out your show meaning keeping
the volume as loud as it can without
crackling for all parts of your episode
whether you don't come in with the best
quality where your settings might be off
or maybe the person you've interviewed
their settings are off so I'm going to
take you to a site called auphonic
that's au ph o ni c and i'll show you
how that works ok so here we are at
alphanr.com
cool tool that i use after every episode
just to make sure things are good you
know it reduces a lot of noise and Hum
it makes all the loudness all normalized
in the same you know it sort of balances
the levels for everybody that listens to
the show so let me show you how to use
it really quick I'm gonna log in and use
one password here and you'll see that
I've done a number of episodes in the
past already for a number of different
shows that I've done now I'm going to
click on new production now note that
they give you at this point in time at
least two hours for free to do that for
some of you might only be two episodes
but you know you could try it out see if
you like it
pricing is based on you know bulk
purchases and you know all that stuff I
won't go over that right now but again
it's a really cool and handy tool that I
use it comes with a lot of features as
well you can even export your file after
it goes through all that normalization
stuff and balancing with all the basic
metadata that you want for your show you
can use this if you want for metadata
but I'm sure Tim or somebody else will
teach you how to do that you don't need
to do that I just do it through iTunes
specifically so I can drop my artwork in
there and all that stuff so I'm just
going to use this just to normalize
these particular episodes and I'll show
you how to do the one we just did so I'm
gonna click on choose file I'm going to
go into our podcast folder click on
episodes get that mp3 file that we just
got click open and I'm just going to go
down to the bottom and you know the
default settings are already there and
hit start production and then hit start
production again
and you'll see it's not going to take
that long because the file is really
short but it'll show you sort of a
waveform and a place to download that
particular episode and alright that
episode is done I'm going to click
download just to download it to my
computer and that's the main file you
want to use as far as putting your
metadata in your cover art upload to
your server whatever server you end up
using and then you know having your RSS
feed from your blog and then have it
sent out to iTunes and everywhere else
you have it so before I let you go
there's one final thing I want to say
thank you so much for watching this
tutorial I really hope it was helpful
for you now my final piece of advice for
you is this please please with the
information I just served with you
please create a test episode first don't
wait until your first interview don't
wait until you record your first episode
do it now record a 30-second
conversation with a friend put it
through this process and see what it
sounds like actually listen to that
episode on your desktop on your laptop
and especially your mobile device
because most people are listening to
podcast episodes on the go do that and
you're going to know exactly what to fix
if it's not right you're going to make
your life so much easier thank you and
I'll see you at the top of iTunes Tim
thanks so much for giving me the
opportunity to be here and share with
your audience for those of you out there
who want more for me you can go to
smartpassiveincome.com you can also find
me at Pat Flynn on Twitter thanks I'll
see you around thanks for watching this
video guys if you want more videos
please let me know what you would like
to see how to instructionals whatever it
might be in the comments and please be
sure to subscribe to this YouTube
channel so you don't miss any new videos
that I put out I'll be doing a lot in
video and TV and there's some very cool
stuff coming thanks for watching